en dehors de la chine continentale des
malades dans une trentaine de pays du
monde
un ralentissement du nombre quotidien de
décès a notamment été notifié si ce
dernier bilan semble confirmer une
décrue l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a lancé un appel à la prudence
il est impossible de prévoir quelles
directions l'épidémie prendra nous
demandons à tous les gouvernements
toutes les sociétés et tous les
organismes de presse de travailler avec
nous pour déclencher le niveau d'alarmé
idoine sans souffler sur les braises de
l'hystérie l'épidémie maintient la
planète en alerte
un seul mot d'ordre aujourd'hui la
coopération la chine a un solide système
de santé publique
la chine a un solide système
scientifique et de découverte
la chine a la capacité de développer et
d'augmenter la production de vaccins
nous devons donc travailler avec la
chine
des experts internationaux dépêchés à
pékin par l' oms ont commencé à étudier
l'épidémie du nouveau coronavirus
qu'ovide 19 avec leurs homologues
chinois
une collaboration dont le monde entier
espèrent qu'elle portera ses fruits
rapidement